My guest this week is the
Oscar-winning American actor,
producer and world-class
archer, Geena Davis.
After shooting to fame in
films such as Beetlejuice,
she's spent a large part
of her career now
championing gender diversity
across the media.
I want to ask her today
though about what words
of advice Dustin Hoffman gave her
when dealing with tricky male costars
and how Susan Sarandon changed her life
when they filmed their iconic
Thelma and Louise movie.
Welcome Geena Davis,
lovely to have you here.
Thank you.
Congratulations on the memoir as well.
And I think there's a theme in there
that people may be surprised by,
which is faking it until you make it.
The idea that you as an
actor got your confidence
as you were going through your career,
not the other way around.
Tell me about that.
Right, yeah, I was a badass onscreen
way before I ever felt
like that in real life,
but the roles I played
actually had an impact
on me personally.
And I think exactly as you
said, fake it till you make it,
that I was practicing
being somebody confident
and comfortable in the world.
And it was like an
opportunity to try it on
and then incorporate it in my real life.
How long do you think it took?
How old were you when maybe
you felt like a badass
in real life?
Well, maybe around Thelma
and Louise was the first time
that I felt like, yeah, I
could be like this person.
Yeah, if you go on a
crime spree with a woman
on a road trip.
Exactly, I haven't really
gone on any crime sprees yet,
but it's there, the potential is there.
We will definitely come
back to Thelma and Louise,
but that was in your mid-30s.
so maybe around that point.
Yes, mid-30s.
The book is called 'Dying
of Politeness' and as part
a dedication to your
parents who I was fascinated
even changed the spelling of
your name to avoid awkwardness.
Right, well, it wasn't
that they changed it.
My real name, or my
given name was Virginia.
And since my aunt was Ginny,
they didn't wanna have the same nickname.
So my three-year-old brother
actually came up with Geena.
I don't know how he spelled
it when he said it out loud,
but my mom always made it G-E-E-N-A.
And later, she said, "People seem to love
"the way your name is spelled."
I said, yeah, I just tell
them you didn't know how
to spell Gina.
And she said, "Oh, no, no,
"I grew up in an Italian neighborhood.
I know exactly how to spell it."
Well, why did you spell it with two Es?
"Well, I didn't want anyone
to think it was 'gina."
Like vagina?
Yeah, as in va.
And it was like, oh my God,
my whole identity is based
on fear of vagina.
And fear of stepping out of line
or drawing too much attention,
which is a big part of what
you talk about growing up.
Absolutely, absolutely.
And yet, you went on to be an actor,
to be the center of attention.
See, that's the weird thing
was that from minute one,
I wanted to be an actor from
when I was three or something,
which is to invite people to look at you,
but I didn't want anyone to look at me.
I wanted to be smaller
and take up less space,
but maybe, this is only in hindsight,
maybe I realized if I could
pretend to be somebody else,
I could be more, have a fuller life
if I could pretend to be someone else.
Because you started with modeling as well,
which is the ultimate look at me.
Right, right, exactly.
Just about unwanted looking, though.
It's interesting, a lot of your writing,
a lot of your work is about
women, but it's the advice
from a male co-star quite
early on, Dustin Hoffman,
he gives you a line if you are
gonna have unwanted advances
from male costars.
Tell us about that.
Yes, he was giving me advice every day
when I was working with him and he said,
"Never sleep with your costars."
"It's just a bad idea, it's not good.
"So here's what you say."
And he told me to say, "Thank
you, you're very attractive,
"I would love to, but I don't wanna ruin
"the sexual tension between us."
And then I had to use it on
somebody who was Jack Nicholson.
Yeah, not just anyone,
it was Jack Nicholson.
Yeah, it was Jack Nicholson. I was still-
I had done Tootsie, but
I was also still a model.
And my modeling agent took me
and a couple of other models
who were also actresses
or wanted to be actresses
to LA and he knew Jack
Nicholson for some reason.
And so every night, we had
dinner with Jack Nicholson
for this week.
And then one time I got
back home to the hotel
and there was a message, Geena,
please call Jack Nicholson.
I was like, call Jack Nicholson?
Okay, and I, "Hello, Mr. Nicholson."
"This is Geena, the model."
And he says, "Hey, Geena,
when's it gonna happen?"
I was like, why didn't I realize
this was gonna be what it was about?
But then I was like, I know what to say.
So I said, well, Jack,
you know, I have a feeling
that we're gonna be
working together someday
and I would hate to have ruined
the sexual tension between us.
And he was like, "Oh man,
where'd you get that from?"
But it worked.
Did you say Dustin Hoffman?
Or you kept it to yourself?
No, I didn't, I didn't.
Okay, because what's
interesting about that line
and in the book, you are
exploring your responses
and criticizing yourself as well at times.
You call yourself a wimp, you
say all these sorts of things
and of course it's the power
of hindsight and experience.
But that particular line Dustin
Hoffman gave you is still
about flattering the male ego.
Yes, exactly because it included,
I would love to, you're
very attractive, right.
So would you still use that sort of line
or what do you make of that?
Has it stood the test of time?
Well, no, I wouldn't need that line now.
Now I'd just like, nah, whatever.
But I suppose it shows
you the precariousness
of the women's role in
these working environments.
Right, right, yeah, that he
felt it would be necessary
for me to boost their
ego at the same time,
instead of saying, no,
I'm not interested in you.
Yes, well, one of the men
that you also write about
is Bill Murray and you
talk about working with him
and you describe...
I thought I'd let you
describe it, an incident
that goes on against your consent.
How would you describe what happened?
Right, well, it was inappropriate
from minute one of meeting him.
I had gone to a hotel to meet
with him, he was the director
of this movie also.
And there as a co-director
there and a producer,
so it wasn't a booby trap or something
where I was gonna be alone
with him in a hotel suite.
But as soon as I walked in, he said,
"Have you ever tried the
thumper," which was some kind
of massage device, a huge massage device.
And I was like, no, no and
went to sit down and he said,
"No, no, you have to try it.
"You have to try it, try it.
"You have to lay on the bed and try it."
And I was like, no, no.
And I tried my hardest to be polite
and certainly I'm not gonna do that.
And then he was so relentless
that I realized I'm not
gonna get out of here
until I do this.
And so I perched partway on the bed
and he put it on my back, but that was--
that was very questionable.
You know what that was about.
And I mean, would you describe that...
How would you describe that?
Well, it turned out later that I found out
that he was worried I was
gonna think that I was all that
because I had just won an
Oscar, and that I would be
on the set and think that
I'm superior to people,
I don't know what he thought.
But that was to see if he
could make me do something
I didn't wanna do.
Okay, which is a real power
play and very uncomfortable.
It's a huge power play, yeah.
But the reason I ask is because
of the way we describe things
now perhaps has changed again
when you look back on things.
And I wonder why perhaps
you don't describe it
in stronger terms.
Well, right, because even I'm realizing
after the book was done and everything
that when I describe
it, instead of talking
about how inappropriate his behavior was,
I'm talking about, I was so sad to see
that I wasn't the kind of person yet
who could prevent that from happening,
instead of, really it's
all about his behavior.
But I suppose there's
still a restraint to you
when you're doing this.
I'm still dying of politeness
or maybe slightly in danger
of dying of politeness.
But of course, you've taken
work with your institute
where you look at bias, you
look at behavior and yet,
it's interesting you can't
quite bring it about yourself
and about these sorts of high profile men
that you're willing to
name and talk about.
Right, yeah, I wonder if
that has something to do
with why I was so interested
in women's empowerment
and everything is that I felt not powerful
and I wanted to try to help
myself as well as others.
I think Bill Murray's
been in the news again
in only the last few days.
It's been alleged he settled,
had a financial settlement
with a female production assistant
over allegedly straddling this woman,
kissing over masks on set.
He said there's a difference of opinion,
but shooting was stopped
on the production.
And we're in 2022.
What's your response to that?
That he said it was a
difference of opinion?
Yeah, and the whole story.
Yeah, yeah, it's bad, it's bad.
It's utterly inappropriate.
I mean, that anyone could think
that that was a difference
of opinion when she was
forced to do something
that she didn't want to do,
that's not the definition
of what happened.
But I suppose hearing
that story and about...
I mean, it's alleged
I'll say at this point
and I know you don't know the details,
I don't know the details,
but all this time on, how
does that make you feel
when you've just described
something that happened to you
at the end of the '80s with the same guy?
Well, look, yeah, I wasn't
under the impression
that he would've changed necessarily.
But I suppose the world has changed.
The world has changed.
There was a moment of change
you thought, you hoped
after Thelma and Louise.
Yes.
And you actually say in the book,
nothing changed afterwards.
But you say everything
in your life changed
when you met Susan
Sarandon, professionally so
and also had a big impact
personally for you.
What did she have that you
didn't have at that time?
An ease and self-confidence
in any situation,
she knew what she thought about things,
she knew how to react in the moment.
I mean I was living in a
world where hours or minutes
or days later, I would
realize what I could've said
or should've said or should've done.
And she just lived in the
moment and was very comfortable
sharing what she thought.
I mean, I'm not saying that
she was confrontational,
but she just had an immediate ease
and knew how she felt about
things when they happened.
And I came to realize that
I didn't even know how I...
Forget about that I didn't
say what I was thinking,
I didn't even know how
I felt about situations
until I had time to think about it.
But from minute one, I was like,
wow, I never met anybody like you before.
I do love the fact that
women come up to you still
and say, "It's our favorite
movie, we've acted it out."
You probably get worried about that.
I know, I'm like, hmm,
I don't think you did.
I mean, at least, what part do
you think you're acting out?
But I think we went on
a weekend, just us girls
or something like that, but if you think
about the stuff we do...
You know, people think of
Thelma and Louise as examples
or maybe a little bit
role models slightly,
but nothing we do should be emulated
except being in charge of our own fate.
That was the thing.
That was the whole driving
force in it, but the rest,
the details, the crime elements...
The rest was kind of criminal, yeah.
Have you ever been on a
real-life road trip with Susan?
No, no, but I was thinking only recently
that that would be a cool reality show
is Susan and I driving around the country.
Think we'll have a sequel?
Everyone who asks you about
that, I know you get very...
I'm not asking that, but the
idea of you two together.
Right, right, driving around.
Have you asked, you should ask her?
I should ask her, I know!
I mean we would love it.
Is she still in your
life, are you friends?
Oh yeah, we're still
very good friends, yeah.
She's fantastic to be with.
She would often say when we were shooting,
"See how much fun it
is to work with women?"
And I was like, yes.
You talk about the roles
drying up as you got older.
You never thought it would happen to you.
I like the way you
describe it, it's awful,
but you say forced retirement.
I know that you're very polite,
but are you angry about that?
It made me angry and very sad,
but sometimes you replace
anger with sadness.
Yeah, but if you were to
really let it out, Geena,
in this studio and you know-
it's not a laughing matter it's-
No, no, it wasn't and I'd
heard about this phenomenon
from the very beginning
that roles drop off
for women once they reach 40,
but I thought Meryl Streep
and all these other female
actors were gonna fix it.
And even if it's still true,
that won't happen to me
because I'm in League of
Their Own and all that stuff.
So it was stunning to
see it also happen to me.
Yeah, and then I talked about
the Geena Davis Institute
on Gender in the Media looking
at female representation.
I know you've set things up
like the Bentonville Film
Festival to look at this.
What have you learned through that work
that you feel perhaps is
going to help change things?
Right, what I focus on with my institute
is onscreen representations.
And I started the whole thing
because I had a daughter
and started watching
preschool shows with her
and saw a huge gender imbalance.
So I'm like, wait a
minute, we're training them
from minute one to have
unconscious gender bias.
Girls see there's not many of them there,
boys see we do all the interesting things.
So that really spurred me on
to wanna try to change that.
But most creators, most
writers, most studio head people
with green light power are male
and so, you have to be able to...
In order to achieve what
I wanted to achieve,
you have to get the men in power also
to see the problem and wanna fix it.
And where do you feel we are with that?
I mean, as we talk, Harvey
Weinstein's back in court,
we've obviously had the Me Too movement,
but do you feel we're in a better place?
Well, as far as children's
entertainment, I can tell you
that in the 18 years since
we started my institute,
we have achieved parity
in the lead characters
in both children's television
and movies made for families.
So that's a huge difference
from when we started,
but progress in other areas
is pretty glacial as far
as female directors or
editors or cinematographers.
So your mood at the moment about that
would you say is optimistic,
are you in a pragmatic place,
where would you say you are?
I am an impatient optimist.
I'm always feeling like we can
get there, we can get there,
but it's in some years,
it's gonna take decades
to reach parity.
We can't snap our fingers
and suddenly Congress is half women.
It's gonna take decades.
We've still only seen a
woman in the White House
when it's played on
television or in the films,
not quite ready yet for
whatever the reason.
For whatever the reason.
Can I ask, while this forced
retirement's happening,
I know that's when you were
having your children as well,
but that wasn't the reason as discussed,
you take archery.
I have to ask about this.
It's one of my favorite facts
I did not know about you
and you're really good at it.
Yeah.
Yeah, how did that happen?
It makes sense if I explain it.
So I had been very unathletic as a kid.
I was so tall that I was sure
that I must be uncoordinated,
so I didn't wanna try anything.
And then I got cast in
A League of Their Own
to play the best baseball
player anyone's ever seen.
So of course I had to
train and try to learn
and I was kinda good at it.
And I was able to pull off
looking like I really know how
to play baseball.
And I did learn it to some extent.
And then I had to learn other
skills for other movies,
sword fighting and horseback
riding and Taekwondo
and different things.
And I was good at all those, too.
So then I thought, I
wonder if in real life,
I would be good at a sport
and what would I choose?
And I happened to see
archery on television
during the '96 Olympics.
And I thought, wow,
archery is so beautiful.
It's very dramatic and
maybe I'll be good at that.
And so found a coach, took it up at 41
and then became utterly obsessed with it.
I mean, you nearly went and
represented your country?
Well, I was a semi-finalist
in the Olympic trials.
Which is incredible!
I know, the last thing I ever expected was
to find myself in the
Olympic trials in my 40s.
What do you think it was
about the sport and you?
I think I probably had a bit
of a natural hand-eye
coordination or something,
but I dove into it.
I became utterly obsessed.
I was practicing four hours
a day and I don't know,
I just was very determined.
Well, also just talking
about later on in your life,
a late diagnosis of ADHD as well,
what did that mean for you?
How did that explain or
unpack some of your world?
It was such a relief to find out
that I didn't have a
character flaw necessarily
because my entire life, as a kid as well,
I couldn't start things,
I couldn't finish them.
Once we started having
homework that took more
than one night to do, I had no
ability to stretch things out
and it was very, very difficult.
And I was ashamed of that
that this was something wrong with me.
So for my whole life, it's
something I had to hide
that I can't complete things and all that.
But as soon as I found I
was diagnosed with ADD,
I was like, oh my God,
that explains everything!
It was such an awakening.
And so, okay, so in other
words, I can start feeling like
this is not my fault, this
doesn't mean I'm a bad person,
you know what I mean?
This is who you are.
And did you take anything for it
or did it change your approach?
I didn't end up taking
any medication for it,
but it did change my approach.
It made me realize that
I needed coping skills
that would help deal with that.
So for example,
if I felt like I wasn't
gonna practice archery
on a certain day which I wanted to,
but am I gonna make myself get in the car?
I would make an appointment
for a brief time with
my coach in the morning.
And then once I'm there, I
could stay all day and practice,
but little tricks like that.
Would you like to do a lot
more acting again, though?
Oh yeah, absolutely, absolutely.
That's my thing, acting is my thing.
That's what I wanna do.
Yeah, well, at the same time,
you've obviously kept yourself very busy.
But I was thinking about
to, we had Gloria Allred
on the program, the feminist lawyer
and she was talking about
women getting more radical
as they get older.
Do you feel that has happened to you?
Well, so I worked with Polly Bergen once,
who was a famous actress.
When I worked with her, she was 80,
but she had been quite famous
and I couldn't believe
how salty she was on set.
She was swearing here and there, you know?
And I was like, wow, Polly, you really...
Yeah, you're kinda like a sailor.
And she said, "Oh, when
you get to be my age,
"you just don't give a anymore."
And I was like, okay,
then I'm gonna be like you
when I get to be your age.
This is where I'm heading for.
Yeah.
And are there any dream roles for you
that you think about?
There's one real-life character
that I would like to play,
who is Eleanor Roosevelt.
And the great thing about that is
she was famous her whole life,
so I'm not gonna age out
of being able to play her.
And she was very tall like me.
I think I could look very much like her.
Yeah, well, there's a great
quote that's always attributed
to her about a woman being like a tea bag.
You don't know how strong she is
till you put her in hot water.
I don't know if it is definitely her,
but I got given it on a pin cushion.
Oh, I love that.
That's a great quote.
So okay, we've sorted
it, Eleanor Roosevelt
and you're gonna do a
reality TV show with Susan.
Sure, yeah.
Well, it's lovely to talk to you
and hear some of your memories
you've shared in the book,
but also where you think
we're at, at the moment.
Geena Davis, thank you so much.
Thank you.
And thank you so much for being with us.
Until we meet again,
take care and goodbye.